hey guys be here this is my recap and
review for 20 season 3 part 8 this is
your spoiler warning if you haven't
watched part 8 of the return of Twin
Peaks you're going to want to stop
watching this video right now
alright I've watched an ivory watch part
eight and came to the same conclusion we
learned a lot in this episode while some
of what we saw didn't exactly paint a
crystal clear image it did illustrate
some major themes in a fairly
straightforward way and last week I was
talking about how the different
storylines move at different paces this
did move one particular storyline
forward and that is the story of Bob so
I'm not sure I see my scene breakdown as
such is relevant here since it's what
I've been doing though I'll kind of head
in that direction we start out with ray
and evil coupe driving on the highway
after leaving the prison were reminded
of the evil ones abilities when he pulls
out his phone and tells ray that their
car has three tracking devices on it
using his seemingly magically
technologically crazy phone to redirect
the signal to a truck that's driving in
front of them by entering its
license-plate number into it they're
able to drive without being tracked
he inserts a phone out the window and
after ray points out that they're
probably going to come to look for them
and asked him about Daria we find out
they're headed to a place called the
farm could this be related to the
character that was credited as the
farmer in the last week's episode I
don't know really there was something
weird going on at that guy's place that
part was clear but I'm guessing that
that would be somewhere in the
neighborhood of 1500 miles from where
they are at the time so driving in that
direction doesn't you know that's not
necessary close that it's driving less
they would be driving that way but I'm
not sure that we can make that jump as
far as that's where they're headed is to
see that guy anyway
evil coupe reminds Ray that he has
information that he wants ray tells them
that he has the numbers memorized but
has realized that they might be worth
some money
they get off the highway and go down at
we're ray asked if he can pull over
because he has to take a leak he goes
mr. C checks the glove box for the gun
gets out of the car and then we find out
things are not as they seem as evil
coupe presses for the info we find out
that his gun doesn't were that Ray has
set him up and has a gun that does work
and then Ray proceeds to shoot him twice
in the chest when I glossed over the
reality that I'm not sure how Ray was
able to pull this off and move on to the
aftermath as he's walking over to put
one final bullet into his head we see
some flickering light and then realized
they are no longer in the woods alone a
swarm of what I was previously calling
or referring to as the guy covered in
oil comes rushing out of the woods so
there's not one guy or one guy in the
cell and the second one in the morgue
there are tons of them ray doesn't enjoy
their company and sort of just sits
there and moans while they proceed to
dance around and smear evil coups blood
on his face when he falls it looks to me
like Bob's hair is superimposed on him
sort of like what we saw in the mirror
at the prison while they're doing their
thing we actually see Bob's head emerge
from his abdomen in an orb I know where
Bob went isn't clear but if I had to
guess I would say he's no longer
inhabiting Hooper's doppelganger ray
runs to the car and takes off at this
point and the oily guys swarm
then disappears pretty much in short
order as he's driving away ray calls
Philip Jefferies and tells him that he
thinks he killed evil COO but that he
had had some help so he wasn't a hundred
percent sure he says he saw something in
Cooper it's may be the key to what is
all what this is all about and that he
told him where he was going so if he
comes after him he'll just get him there
from there we get a musical performance
from The Nine Inch Nails as the MC
introduces them and for me this was the
one part that I was sort of like okay I
mean it's a good song I don't have a
problem with it it just seemed out of
place but considering what followed
afterwards I guess it's sort of like a
transition or almost like
intermission in-between what you know
what happened in the beginning and what
happened after I didn't see anything
going on in the scene and really for me
I jaqen like I said the song was fine
and whenever I just sort of drifted a
little bit which makes me think that
maybe it was for that reason like I
first thought are they really going to
play the whole song and then I started
thinking thinking things like man that
sure is probably hot up there with
leather jackets and everything that's
pretty tough to have to stand in front
of those hot lights wearing all those
clothes but anyways as they finish up we
see Evil coupe wake up and not much else
we don't know I mean he's not dead we
know that after the transition we go
back in time well historically speaking
we see something we see July 16 to 1945
the White Sands New Mexico at 5:29 a.m.
this is a real thing this is the first
atomic test in the United States or
anywhere for that matter and this is
where the episode sort of goes in the
different direction so we see the
detonation we see the awesome power of
the explosion and then we travel
visually inside of that said reaction I
thought this was a nice scene to look at
I didn't have a problem with its length
I guess it just worked for me but I know
people started to you know wonder what
the heck was going on really all that's
going on here is we're seeing a nuclear
explosion close up at first it's worth
mentioning the piece that's playing in
the background here the musical piece
it's from a guy who was an avant-garde
composer his name is Christoph ten Direk
and the musical piece is called serenity
for the victims of Hiroshima
of course I didn't know what this was I
relied on the internet for that and if
you're like me the word Trinity is not
in your vocabulary so I looked it up and
it means aliment so this piece is a
lament for the Victims of Hiroshima
which are obviously the people who died
whenever we drop the first atomic bomb
the United States dropped the first
atomic bomb on Hiroshima which is very
fitting from there we see a convenience
store it's sort of an old-timey one in
1945 and we see what I'm going to call
simplicity from now on the woodsman the
hobo like characters who have been
covered in oil and other scenes we see
them sort of milling around and waiting
I mentioned in my top moments video why
this is exciting I mean the convenience
store has been something that a lot of
us have been speculating about for years
so this was a really exciting moment
after we watch the woodsman for a while
we get a cut to a mother like figure
it's a female form not quite human by
any stretch of the imagination but you
get my drift we see her spew for lack of
a better term a stream of liquid or gel
or insert your favorite word here but in
that stream we see Bob's head inside of
a orb we also see what looks to me like
a bunch of those eggs that we'll see
later
I'm not going to speculate wildly on
that stuff right now but basically this
is Bob entrance into our story after we
see him float by we go back to the
explosions and we see a piece of what
looks like liquid gold gold metal that's
been liquefied sort of floating there
and then we return to the mob zone or
that part of the universe I guess we
could say we see the the vast purple
ocean and we sort of fly into the void
until we arrive at a structure that is
gigantic and we go through a window and
we arrive in a room where we see a woman
dressed in an evening gown she looks
like she's ready to go out we see what
we're going to call a bell like we saw
in part three we see the phonograph
player that we saw in part one and
basically at first she's just sitting
there listening to the music an alarm
goes off and the giant appears to me it
looks like they sort of communicate
telepathically I don't know if that's
important but you know he sort of looks
at her she looks at him
there are no words but it seems like
that they are in communication he walks
to the foreground he sort of looks in
our direction thanks for a period of
time while the alarms going off then he
walks over to the Bell and flips over
pushes a button I guess would be the
best thing I could say here after that
he leaves that room he goes up some
stairs he passes through a much larger
chamber that has a much larger Bell that
looks to be two stories at least and he
arrives in a theater upstairs that many
people have pointed out is the same as
Club Silencio and Mahal and drive there
he watches on a movie screen what we
just saw he sees the explosion he sees
Bob enter into the world at that he
starts to float he levitates up towards
the ceiling we start to see some golden
light pour out of him almost looks like
stars the woman from downstairs comes up
starts to watch what's happening and we
see that a golden orb is created like he
creates this thing out of himself
it floats down to his companion who
looks at the orb and sees Laura Palmer's
face inside he gives it a kiss then lets
it go it passes through some
indescribable little kind of machinery
or whatever you want to call this here
but it's a tube but it takes the end and
then it transfers it from their world
into our world via the movie screen
after that we return to the New Mexico
desert we see time advance from 1945 to
1956 and then we see the egg hatch from
the egg we see a creature that we will
say is a moth frog this is a reference
to something that they have at lunch
that said before so just whatever bear
with me on that and it crawls away then
we meet two brand new characters in 1956
New Mexico couple of teenagers it looks
like they're coming from a dance based
on what they're talking about and the
boy is walking the girl home they pass
by what could be that exact same
convenience store although there's no
way to know but it looks like it may be
an
dated version buildings a little bit
bigger the gas pumps are a little bit
more modern but either way they walk
home when they arrive at her house he
tells her he wants the kiss she lets him
give her one then goes inside and that's
about it for right there while they're
walking we saw a guy who is credited as
the woodsman in the credits which is a
callback to the scene above a
convenience store and the missing pieces
from fire walk with me
he sort of flies in and starts walking
through the desert we find out he's not
alone and him and his companions come up
to a car that's driving through the
desert and he repeats the line got a
light as he's holding a cigarette people
in the car obviously freaked out and
they take off and it's definitely worth
noting here that we heard the electrical
sound that we've been hearing not the
giant sound from the phonograph but the
other sound that we've been hearing in
present day when Peaks after the young
girl at heads inside to her house we see
the woodsman walk up on the local radio
station he goes inside he kills the
receptionist by squeezing her head he
continues to say got a light to everyone
he meets this time though he kills them
he takes over the radio station takes
the needle off the record turns on the
microphone and begins to repeat this
saying this is the water and this is the
well drink full and descend the horse is
the white of the eyes and dark within
and this turns out to be hypnotic and
starts to put all the people who are
listening to the radio station to sleep
that would include the young girl that
we saw with the young boy who has just
come into her house very pleased that
she got a kiss from the boy she
stretches out on her bed and falls
asleep where the other people just sort
of fall wherever they were the egg
hatchling the moth frog makes its way to
her windowsill the woodsman keeps
continuing to repeat the mantra or the
hypnotic chant
or the whatever it is and the creature
crawls onto her bed and crawls into her
mouth the woodsman finish the DJ off and
then he wanders out of the radio station
into the dark it's worth noting here
that we hear a horse name whenever he
gets out into the black the end credits
come up and we see the girl sleeping
peacefully with her New France a friend
inside of her so okay a lot of people
won't like this episode right off the
bat because it is non-conventional in
nature I mentioned in my top moments
video that I thought it was enjoyable
like I didn't really lose interest The
Nine Inch Nails thing stretched a little
bit but overall once the ride began from
the mushroom cloud I was I was compelled
I really wanted to see I mean I assumed
that we were looking into the white log
so I was just kind of fascinated I mean
we saw a convenience store all this and
I realized some people wouldn't have had
that same experience so what do we think
actually happened here because I saw a
common comment that people were posting
was what did I just see I think a really
simple way to answer that is we saw the
introduction of evil into our world now
I don't usually speculate wildly on
things I usually just lay out what we've
seen and started discussing so this is
my opinion on my experience of watching
it I'm not saying any but you know set
in stone it's really just to get the
conversation rolling so my conclusion
was man had had done something it had
never done at that time it harness
destructive power on a scale that is one
of the most important things that's
happen in human history basically in
that process we saw we saw a door being
opening am I in my interpretation where
Bob could come into our world we know
Bob well from this series but we don't
really know where he came from and other
than like the Red Room right we've seen
him in the room above the convenience
store we've seen him running around in
our world inside of different people but
the prior to this we really didn't know
where he came from or why he existed and
while this doesn't appear to me to be a
origin scene of the lodges and
general it certainly shows how Bob got
into our world now I remember reading
something a while ago maybe years ago at
this point about Bob being the evil that
men do you know like he is the evil
that's in all of us kind of a thing and
it made a lot of sense and what was
interesting about it to me was that you
know Bob he inhabits people and they do
horrific things and you kind of get the
idea that it's not that far from our
normal human behavior to do really crazy
awful things
so by detonating the bomb that opened
the gateway to where he came in in
reaction to this the giant who we
considered to be on the good side of
things created Laura who would be at
least in my interpretation at the
beginning of this creation the
embodiment of what is good about us or
love he sent her into the world and a
sort of balance you know we have a
balance of good and evil we see men do
something we see evil do something and
then we seek the good side of things
react now if you're wondering why Laura
would be considered good based on the
you know her behavior in fire walk with
me it's important to realize here that
she was corrupted by Bob at an early age
right he came into the world and it
doesn't look like it was a coincidence
that he ended up in happening her father
I'm not able to explain any of that so I
won't try but to keep things on track we
have a struggle between good and evil as
mentioned I don't know who these kids
are they're they're not supposed to be
anybody that we would recognize at first
glance the ages the time there's a lot
of stuff to consider I won't speculate
on that too much I'll just say that at
least for now it appears that after an
incubation period Bob hatched as this
mock fog and with the help of the
woodsman who are definitely helping him
at all points of this episode he was
able to enter a host which is this young
girl who we don't know who she is
so I'm going to leave it at dad that's
my simplest interpretation of it I
definitely want to hear what you guys
think in the comments and because we are
without Twin Peaks
next week it's not on I'm definitely
going to be jumping into some extra
videos between now and then please let
me know what you think I got right or
what I got wrong and remember this is
subjective I mean this was the most
subjective episode so far so it doesn't
matter if it makes perfect sense it was
the experience of watching it for me
that made it good and I do think that
the things that I brought up here are
very close to what's going on in the
Twin Peaks universe so let's have a
debate let's have the talk if you hated
it tell me why you hated it did this
change your mind at all if you loved it
what was your favorite parts please like
the video if you found it enjoyable
please subscribe to my channel it's been
great getting all the comments and
getting all the interaction on Twitter
so follow me over there too if you
that's where I kind of hang out most of
the time for better or worse and thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon